la loi Claisse Leonetti ce sont trois
grands principes c'est le principe du
droit à une fin de vie digne
c'est le principe du refus de
l'obstination des raisonnables
et c'est la volonté d'un accès pour tous
aux soins palliatifs
ce rapport est Laborde évidemment la
question des soins palliatifs dont on
mesure qu'aujourd'hui
l'accès est très insatisfaisant dans
notre pays par la sédation profonde
continue c'est une pratique rare dans
l'unité de soins palliatifs de Juvisy
que nous avons visité qui comporte 10
lits de soins palliatifs et qui
accueille environ 200 patients par an
on nous a dit que cette pratique de la
sédation profonde et continue
survenait deux à trois fois dans l'année
donc une pratique rare mais une pratique
quand même
qui existe et qui est encadré par la loi
on nous donne deux raisons pour cela la
première explication qu'on nous donne
c'est que
elle n'est pas utile que les sédations
proportionnées suffisent et que la
sédation profonde et continue finalement
et le dernier recours
mais qu'en fait voilà c'est un outil
utile mais qu'on utilise assez peu la
loi étant d'ailleurs restrictive
elle-même puisqu'elle ne peut être
appliquée que dans des cas de pronostic
vital à courte durée c'est à dire
quelques heures et quelques jours d'un
autre côté c'est une procédure qui
interroge qui interroge les soignants
qui interrogent les malades
quand ils savent ce que c'est et qui
interroge les familles pourquoi parce
que il y a cette non maîtrise du temps
qui est une angoisse pour tout le monde
le Conseil d'État
qui n'est pas coutumier de jugement
[Musique]
outre que juridique à parler de malade
qui n'en finissent pas de mourir je cite
le Conseil d'État c'est malade qui n'en
finissent pas de mourir